mädchen oder junge frau oder mann diese
beiden auswahlmöglichkeiten reichen
lange nicht denn schätzung zufolge gibt
es mindestens 80.000 menschen in
deutschland die nicht eindeutig sie oder
er sind intersexuell nennt man diese
personen dann jetzt hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden im
geburtenregister muss demnächst ein
dritter geschlechts eintrag möglich sein
was intersexualität genau bedeutet und
weitere spannende facts zum so genannten
dritten geschlecht jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen im
team rosa oder team blau mädchen oder
junge
nicht immer lässt sich bei der geburt
tatsächlich eine eindeutige antwort auf
diese frage finden denn es gibt
neugeborene bei denen das geschlecht
eben nicht eindeutig erkennbar ist
schätzung zufolge ist das bei 1 zu 2000
bis 1 zu 5000 neugeborenen der fall
ihnen wird dann nach der absprache
zwischen ärzten und eltern einfach ein
geschlecht zugewiesen denn die kinder
sind natürlich nicht selbst in der lage
zu entscheiden dann folgen entsprechende
hormonbehandlung und im kleinkindalter
wurden früher fielen dann auch die
genitalien operiert damit sie danach
möglichst eindeutig ein penis oder eine
scheibe haben die betroffenen erfahren
das ganze dann oft sehr viel später die
eingriffe können zu psychischen
problemen führen
und es ist natürlich eine absolute
katastrophe wenn andere über das
geschlecht entschieden haben und damit
falsch liegen deshalb werden solche
geschlechtsumwandlung heute frühestens
mit 14 und besser erst ab 18 gemacht es
gibt zudem noch menschen bei denen nicht
direkt bei der geburt auffällt dass sie
zwischen den geschlechtern sind bei
manchen mädchen entwickelt sich
plötzlich in der pubertät eine tiefe
stimme den jungs wachsen brüste viele
von ihnen sind jahrelang auf der suche
nach ihrer identität bei anderen fällt
es erst im erwachsenenalter auf
beispielsweise werden dann bei einer
vermeintlichen frau boden im bauch
festgestellt hinzu kommt eine wohl hohe
dunkelziffer an menschen die zwischen
den geschlechtern stehen bei denen das
aber nie medizinisch diagnostiziert
worden ist diese menschen die sich also
weder als frauen noch als mann
identifizieren also quasi zwischen den
geschlechtern stehen nennt man
intersexuell das kann auf genetischer
körperlicher oder hormoneller ebene der
fall sein
bisher sind 20 varianten der
intersexualität bekannt manche von ihnen
sind genetisch an mädchen haben aber ein
penis weil ihr körper so viel
testosteron produziert andere sehen
äußerlich aus wie ein mädchen haben aber
ein männliches y-chromosom in ihrem
erbgut doch wie entwickelt sich
überhaupt unsere geschlechtsidentität
dabei spielen mehrere aspekte eine rolle
natürlich gibt es zum einen körperlichen
merkmale aber auch soziale einflüsse
sind bringt die hormone der stoffwechsel
aber auch die anatomie bestimmen
letztendlich dann wie sich eine person
geschlechtlich einordnet und als was sie
sich sexuell identifiziert hierbei
spielen auch das psychische empfinden
und die eigene biografie eine rolle das
große problem der intersexuellen in
unserer gesellschaft ist unsere
gesellschaft denn sie teilt ihnen genau
zwei geschlechter auf und vergisst dabei
schätzungsweise mindestens 80.000
menschen in deutschland die sich eben
nicht eindeutig als sie oder er
identifizieren in formularen
beispielsweise gibt es genau zwei
auswahlmöglichkeiten männlich oder
weiblich frau oder mann
bisher haben sie nur eine möglichkeit
ihr geschlecht im personenregister
austragen zu lassen heißt also kein
geschlecht keine gute option findet auch
das bundesverfassungsgericht in
karlsruhe hat jetzt vor kurzem
entschieden im geburtenregister muss ist
ein drittes geschlecht geben in einer
pressemitteilung von anfang november
heisst es das allgemeine
persönlichkeitsrecht artikel 2 absatz 1
in verbindung mit artikel 1 absatz 1
grundgesetz schützt auch die
geschlechtliche identität derjenigen die
sich dauerhaft weder den männlichen noch
dem weiblichen geschlecht zuordnen
lassen darüber hinaus verstößt das geld
in der personenstandsrecht auch gegen
das diskriminierungsverbot artikel 3
absatz 3 grundgesetz so weit die
eintragung eines anderen geschlechts als
männlich oder weiblich ausgeschlossen
wird bis ende 2018 habe der gesetzgeber
jetzt zeit eine neuregelung zu schaffen
heißt also neben den
auswahlmöglichkeiten männlich oder
weiblich eine weitere positive
bezeichnung des geschlechts aufzunehmen
möglich wären beispielsweise begriffe
wie divers oder inter in seinem
beschluss geht das gericht übrigens von
bis zu 160000 intersexuellen
in deutschland aus die entscheidung wird
von vielen gefeiert der deutsche
ethikrat beispielsweise hatte solch
einen schritt schon 2012 gefordert als
historische entscheidung zur
gleichbehandlung hinter geschlechtlicher
menschen bezeichnet die
antidiskriminierungsstelle des bundes
dem beschluss aus karlsruhe wer übrigens
mehr zum thema erfahren möchte sollte
unbedingt zum thementag hinter
geschlechtlichkeit der humboldt law
klinik für grund- und menschenrechte am
27 november in berlin gehen
den link dazu gibt es hier und natürlich
in der video beschreibung hier geht es
weiter einfach draufklicken dafür mit
einstein und die leute die neueinsteiger
geht es um frauen in der wissenschaft
und ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis
dann bleibt dran